[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 les invités une
émission dédiée à celles et ceux qui
font l'actualité dans le département est
aujourd'hui mercredi 22 février parole
accueillir le bras et jean luc
detavernier membres de l'association le
pays
ile de france une association associer
une association qui souhaite notamment
mobiliser les pouvoirs publics pour la
prise en charge des malades victimes
d'épilepsie sévère et puis dans cette
émission paroles aussi à jean maurice
bonneau l'organisateur du jumping
international de versailles une
compétition équestre qui réunira bientôt
et les 50 meilleurs cavaliers du monde à
versailles on commence donc cette
émission avec vous deux clair le bras et
jean luc detavernier bonsoir franchement
vous êtes donc membre de l'association
des doses adultes épileptiques pour
accompagner leur progression et
favoriser leur intégration le nom le nom
est bond le nom est validé mais bon une
association vous avez créé notamment
vous faire le bras qui en est à
l'initiative l'an passé avec plusieurs
familles est votre principal combat si
je résume bien c'est la prise en charge
des malades en ile de france vous
demander notamment l'ouverture urgente
de plusieurs foyers ou de plus de foyers
en tout cas d'accueil médicalisé pour
adultes c'est bien ça c était votre
objectif initial tout à fait notre
objectif est l'ouverture sur l'île de
france dans les prochaines années le
plus rapidement possible de plusieurs
foyers d'accueil médicalisés dédié aux
épileptiques adultes et spécialement sur
l'épilepsie sévère voilà c'est bien sur
ce volet à vue parce qu'aujourd'hui ceux
qui ne sont pas de son plus ou moins
bien pris en charge ce n'est pas que le
garder à 12 tout à fait alors
c'est tout à fait le cas c'est vraiment
plus ou moins puisque même dans le monde
des enfants et des adolescents
les prises en charge sont rares voilà
sur le sur l'île de france il ya
seulement 2 2 établissements en internat
qui accueille les enfants et les
adolescents
jusqu'au 20 ans sur la prise en charge
de l'épilepsie sévère alors quand on
parle justement d'épilepsie sévère on
parle de quoi précisément est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer bien sur
l'épilepsie sévère est une épilepsie
pharmacorésistante donc résistante
autres m
au traitement non stabilisé et qui
provoquent des troubles des acquisitions
des enfants et des jeunes des jeunes
adultes qui ont cette maladie troubles
des acquisitions cognitives sensorielles
moteur etc et qui est donc forcément et
c'est logique très très contraignant
pour les pour les malades qui
nécessitent un suivi 24 heures sur 24
pour évidemment les malades mais aussi
pour les proches vous êtes vous-même
mère d'une jeune fille atteinte d'une
maladie épileptique sévère comment ça se
passe concrètement au quotidien
le quotidien est difficile nous sommes
sur l'épilepsie sévère nos enfants sont
souvent atteints en nourrissons ou un
jeune enfant
voilà donc le parcours est long et
difficile très peu d'hôpitaux peuvent
les prendre en charge sur sur paris ou
l'ile-de-france au niveau de l'épilepsie
sévère et c'est un parcours du
combattant très vite sur leur prise en
charge scolaire ou semi scolaires et
éducatives
on va pour bien comprendre l'enjeu est
la problématique de votre association
parlé un petit peu chiffres et du coup
je me tourne je me tourne vers vous jean
luc detavernier nous expliquer un peu
les chiffres de l'épilepsie et
l'épilepsie sévère en ile de france ça
concerne combien de personnes combien de
centres sont sont adaptés à ces
personnes haussier alors l'épilepsie en
france et six cent mille personnes qui
en sont atteintes
suit représente abri 115 mille personnes
en ile de france et quand on parle plus
spécifiquement d'épilepsie sévère sa
touche de 1500 personnes ile de france
il s'agit de à la fois d'enfants et
d'adultes à peu près pour moitié chacune
donc c'est une problématique qui est
aujourd'hui prise en charge
pour ce qui concerne les adultes par un
seul établissement en ile de france un
seul établissement dans la glace je
crois tout à fait dans le 91 à frontenay
les bris donc on un seul c'est à dire 40
places pour 2500 personnes pour dire
qu'il ya deux mille quatre cent soixante
personnes qui sont complètement laissés
sur le carreau
j'ai réussi on si on considère
uniquement les adultes c'est
pratiquement moitié donc 1200 personnes
40 places donc vous imaginez qu'il en
manque à certains nombres on va dire
qu'il en manque dans l'île de france 3
par département et peut-être quatre où
cinq sur paris pour aujourd'hui
accueillir effectivement dans des
conditions normales
ces jeunes atteints d'épilepsie serre où
ces jeunes adultes où ces adultes
atteints d'épilepsie sévère donc vous
concrètement qu'est ce que vous demandez
aux pouvoirs publics c'est ses trois
centres par département ou alors c'est
déjà un premier pas c'est à dire un
centre très rapidement quels sont vos
requêtes concrètes le but que s'est fixé
l'association est pile de france et dans
un premier temps d'obtenir un second
établissement
à brève échéance j'ai la chance de
quelques années un second établissement
ouest mais ça n'est même à brève
échéance en parle de quelques années
c'est une brève échéance qui peut
paraître très longue pour beaucoup de
gens brève échéance dans la mesure où
effectivement il faudra sensibiliser la
rs agences régionales de santé
et puis un conseil départemental dans un
des départements d'ile-de-france qui se
montrent trop volontariste pour
effectivement prendre en cause
l'épilepsie aujourd'hui nous disposons
malheureusement pas d'implants épilepsie
comme ça peut être le cas de l'autisme
pour donner une comparaison l'autisme
ses 650 mille personnes atteints
d'autisme
en france on en est au troisième plan et
autisme qui a changé énormément les
conditions de prise en charge de cette
maladie
il n'y a toujours pas de plan épilepsie
et puis si ces six cent mille patients
pourquoi selon vous est ce pour quoi on
a un peu cette impression quand on vous
écoute même s'il faut pas comparer les
maladies ça n'a strictement aucun sens
mais pourquoi n'at on a cette impression
finalement que vous êtes un peu les
oubliés des maladies sévères grave
l'épilepsie est et a toujours été une
une maladie neurologique méconnu sur
lequel il ya pleins pleins d'étiquettes
encore ancien qui se mettent
voilà c'est fort dommage mais c'est
ainsi
aujourd'hui vous appelez j'imagine
beaucoup de familles à vous à vous
rejoindre c'est ça aussi le but de cette
association de créer un mouvement pour
peser plus le but premier de
l'association effectivement c'est de
recueillir d'accueillir un maximum
d'adhérents c'est à dire donner du poids
à l'association par une représentativité
plus importante
six cent mille épileptique signifie
trois millions et demi de personnes
concernées ce sont les parents les
proches des frères et soeurs mais
au-delà de ça et j'en ai fait
l'expérience récemment parlant avec des
amis des relations ou travers
d'activités diverses
de ce que je fais à la retraite c'est à
dire tiens je m'occupe et ça me prend en
ce moment une partie de mon temps d'une
association qui s'occupe de personnes
épileptiques
je suis frappée du nombre de personnes
qui me répondent je suis concerné j'ai
été concernés où j'ai un proche
concernées et du coup pour ceux qui
veulent éventuellement vous rejoindront
va rappeler le site internet pour
terminer là dessus www.pyr.com c'est
bien ça mais elle fait merci clair le
bras et jean luc detavernier de nous
avoir rejoint un plateau et de nous
avoir donné toutes ces informations on
poursuit ce 7,8 les invités avec du
sport imaginer plus de 2000 personnes
réunies dans la cour des grandes écuries
du roi à versailles ajoutez à cela les
50 meilleurs cavaliers mondiaux et vous
obtenez l'un des tournois les plus
prestigieux de cette année 2010 est en
france
le jumping international 5 étoiles a été
présenté officiellement ce mardi dans la
cité royale en présence notamment des
organisateurs des sportifs et de
l'acteur guillaume canet ambassadeurs de
l'événement michael et demi d'euros
notre journaliste était sur place pour
rencontrer le responsable de l'événement
jean maurice bonneau
on les écoute la conférence de presse
pour le jumping international de
versailles vient tout juste de se
terminer et je suis avec l'un des
organisateurs jean maurice bonneau
alors il va nous parler de
l'organisation alors qu'est-ce qu'il va
y avoir ici début mais ici à versailles
eh bien il ya le jumping international
du château de versailles dans la cour
des écuries du roi
donc c'est un concours 5 étoiles on aura
les meilleurs cavaliers du monde on aura
l'équipe de france championne olympique
et pendant trois jours on va mélanger le
sport sport de très très haut niveau
avec bartabas et son académie équestre
et on ça va être un mélange d'histoire
de culture et de sport de très haut
niveau et pourquoi avoir choisi de
l'implanter ici à versailles ce jumping
mais nous sommes déjà organisateur d'un
csi du même niveau d'un à chantilly haut
niveau au milieu de l'hippodrome le long
des grandes écuries et du château de
chantilly
et puis avec notre équipe on a été en
contact avec l'administrateur du château
toute l'équipe qui gère le château de
versailles et l'idée a été de le faire
dans cette dans ce cadre là parce que
l'idée de ramener le cheval à l'endroit
du cheval de l'époque de louis xiv et
bien sûr qu'on pourrait ici ne faire
qu'un concours prestigieux en ramenant
l'excellence donc c'est pour ça que tout
se marie sur le même thème l'excellence
le la qualité la recherche de perfection
est aujourd'hui en tant qu'organisateur
on est conscient de l'enjeu de la
difficulté d'organiser un concours dans
un lieu comme ici mais ça donne beaucoup
d'énergie et on a on a des soutiens on
est d'aider les ambassadeurs de qualité
comme kevin staut qui est champion
olympique rodrigo pessoa qui a été
champion olympique guillaume canet et
puis des partenaires extraordinaire bien
surtout toute l'équipe du château de
versailles la ville de versailles
rolex qui sera le partenaire de notre
grand prix renault également qui revient
dans les sports équestres
tout cet engagement autour de nous nous
incite à vraiment réussir un très très
bel événement
donc les épreuves équestres on se
déroulait ici derrière nous avec
certains éléments ici ce sera la piste
avec les tribunes là-bas derrière et on
aura une épreuve
peuvent la journée et puis des nocturnes
avec 2 les plus grosses épreuves avec
les plus gros enjeu et pour se terminer
le dimanche après midi avec le grand
prix rolex et puis la particularité
c'est aussi que le public aura accès
avec son ticket d'entrée
bien sûr au sport mais aussi à la
galerie des carrosses aux grandes
écuries de l'académie nos partenaires
auront accès eux au théâtre de
l'académie pour suivre une
représentation des écuyères de
l'académie donc encore une fois je
répète mais on va vraiment j'ai mélangé
la culture l'art équestre l'histoire et
le sport de très haut niveau
vous parliez tout à l'heure de kevin
staut ça sera vraiment la tête d'affiche
il a été champion olympique l'été
dernier à rio ça sera la tête d'affiché
de cet événement ça sera une des têtes
d'affiché
parce que on va avoir c'est un local
également il a il est né à auch il est
juste à quelques mètres de là à ce
maillot fera partie des équipes déjà en
équipe de france il ya ses partenaires
de la médaille d'or pénélope leprévost
roger yves bost
philippe rosier puis simon delestre et
donc là on a la chance actuellement
d'avoir une équipe de france très fortes
dans le domaine j'espère que sans être
restant sportifs que ce serait
merveilleux que ce soit en apothéose
soins français qui gagnent le premier
grand prix du château de versailles
mais le sport sera très ouvert on a
aussi ce qui fait la particularité on
aura plusieurs champions olympiques
plusieurs champions du monde qui seront
présents n'a vraiment des têtes de série
ont les engagements définitifs sont pas
encore clos donc on annoncera plus tard
la fiche des stars qui seront là mais on
pourra garantir on peut déjà garantir du
très très grand sport dernière question
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les gens
retiennent de cet événement
j'aimerais que j'aimerais des chattes
les gens qui nous accueillent savez nous
on arrive ici très humblement on est
bien conscient de l'emplacement quand
qu'on va occuper on veut en être digne
et on veut montrer la plus belle manière
notre sport
parce que souvent les gens ne le
connaissent pas et je voudrais que les
gens qui repartaient envie de revenir
l'année prochaine
merci beaucoup jean maurice bientôt
bientôt fin du set 8 les invités pour ce
soir prochain rendez vous demain jeudi
excellente soirée à tous sur tv fil 78
[Musique]